hey everyone my name is gabby mourinho
cesar and i'm with the ibm cloud team
in this video i'm going to show you how
to run batch jobs with ibm cloud code
engine
batch jobs are pieces of code meant to
do specific tasks at specific times of
the day
for example processing records and a
back-end system
so starting at the code engine overview
page we're going to choose the run your
container image option
and give it the name of a batch
container image i'm going to name it hmo
task
to save time the image has already been
built for us
so let's go ahead and hit start creating
to move on to the next step
on this other screen we can enter many
different configuration options
but for now let's just stick with the
defaults for everything except for the
first one
for that one we're going to choose job
instead of application
and with that let's go ahead and hit
create
and now what we have is we've created
the definition of our batch drop
meaning that we didn't actually run it
just yet but we just made the platform
aware of the job itself and so what this
is going to let us do
is it's going to let us run it over and
over again just when we need it
so before we actually run the job let's
first talk about what the job
is going to do for this demo we have an
application
that manages a set of customer records
and the job what it's going to do is
it's going to process
all of the customer records in our
backend system
so you don't need to worry about what
the records are for or what the
front-end application is then we're
showing you
but the key things here are that the two
numbers are from our backend system
the first shows the number of records in
there and the second shows how many have
been processed
so as the batch job runs the second
number will increase and eventually
should equal the first
so now we're just going to move this
window over to the side so that we can
watch it now let's run the batch job by
hitting the submit job button
and you'll notice that there's a few
options that we can also modify
first and foremost is the array indices
field
this tells code engine how many
instances of the job to execute
right now it's showing a default of one
but in the demo we're going to run 10 of
them
so we're actually going to enter 1
through 10.
code engine allows for you to not only
specify how many instances to run
but how those instances are numbered
meaning are they numbered 1
2 and 3 or should we number them
one three five and seven say for example
if you only wanted odd numbered
instances
usually the instance number is used as
part of processing
to ensure that each instance their work
doesn't overlap with any others
so we're going to leave the rest of the
configuration options
and just press submit job
so now what we can see is that we have
10 pending instances
and each instance we're going to see
them move from pending
to running and then eventually completed
notice also in the application window
you can see the number of records
processed
is going up and it's going up pretty
fast
and in a matter of seconds all the 10
jobs are completed
and that's it so let's quickly summarize
what happened
with just the name of a container image
we defined a job
and then we executed it with 10
instances
we didn't have to do any infrastructure
setup no infrastructure management
as a developer of this code all i had to
worry about was the business logic of
the workload and nothing else and that's
the goal of code engine
allowing developers to focus on what's
important their coding
that's all the time we have today but
hopefully you found this quick
walkthrough
of how to manage batch jobs and code
engine exciting
and i encourage you to look at our other
videos to see more
key code engine features and of course
we hope that you'll go to the ibm cloud
code engine page to play with it
yourself thank you